[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
لنتابعا معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وضمن ابرز الاحداث
تل ابيب على واقعي ازمه التغييرات
القضائيه الجيش في النيجر يعزل الرئيس
وتويتر يصبح اكس بالاضافه الى اخبار اخرى
نتابعها معنا
نبدا نشاطنا من التغييرات القضائيه التي
هزه اسرائيل حيث تظاهر بسببها اكثر من نصف
مليون اسرائيلي كانت تنعى الاف الجنود عن
الخدمه ينضم اليها الزميل صهيب العصايه
مرحبا صهيب ما الذي جرى في تل ابيب الذي
جرى بان الكنيست الاسرائيلي اقر اول مشروع
من مشاريع التعديلات او التغييرات
القضائيه التي يسعى نتنياهو اليها والتي
تستهدف بشكل اساسي المحكمه العليا هذا
التغيير يستهدف صلاحياته المحكمه العليا
هناك تغييرات اخرى تستهدف تشكيله المحكمه
العليا في اسرائيل هذا الامر له ارتدادات
في الشارع انقسم المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بطبيعه الحال بين مؤيد ومعارض المعارضون
لهذه التعديلات يقولون ان نتنياهو يدفع
الدوله باتجاه الديكتاتوريه والتحكم
المطلق بكل السلطات وهذا الامر
سيتزايد خلال الفتره القليله القادمه لان
التعديلات ما زالت قائمه والمشاريع ما
زالت قائمه في المقابل الاحتجاجات قائمه
والخوف والقلق بان يتمدد هذا الامر الى
الجيش اذا انقسم الجيش ستكون اسرائيل في
ازمه حقيقيه بطبيعه الحال شكرا يعطيك الف
عافيه مشاهدينا من التطورات في اسرائيل
الى التطورات في النيجر حيث تتسارع
وتطورات بعد اعلان تشكيلي مجلس الانتقالي
برئاسه عبد الرحمن التياني الذي حذر من اي
تدخل عسكري اجنبي واعلن تعليق العملي
بالدستور وحل المؤسسات مجلس الامن والسلم
الافريقي يمهل الانقلابيين 15 يوما للعوده
غير المشروطه الى سكناتهم والافراج عن
الرئيس محمد بازو والاتحاد الاوروبي يقول
انه لا يعترف سوى ببازوم رئيسا للنيجر
واشنطن تقول ان بوسع بازوم الاعتماد عليها
لاستعاده النظاميه الدستوري يمكنكم متابعه
المزيد عن الاحداث هناك في التقرير اسفل
التعليقات نذهب الان الى موضوع اخر اذ
استنكرت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه اعاده
ادراج السلطات المصريه عددا من صح على
قائمه ارهاب جديده وذلك بعد انتهاء مده
تصنيفهم ظلما في القائمه التي تجدد كل خمس
سنوات كما دنت الامم المتحده حبس
الصحافيين والتضييق عليهم في مصر ودعت
شبكه الجزيره السلطات المصريه الى التراجع
والكف عن هذه الخطوات التي تضع العريقين
امام العمل الصحفي وتقيد الحريات كما دعت
الشبكه والامم المتحده والمنظمات الحقوقيه
للضغط على السلطات المصريه لوقف ادراج
الصحافيين على هذه القوائم التعسفيه
وطالبت بالافراج الفوري عن الزميلين ربيع
الشيخ وبهاء الدين ابراهيم المعتقلين وعن
كل الصحافيين المسلوبين في مصر الى طائر
تويتر الازرق الذي طار ولم يعد حيث ازال
ايلون ماسك الشعار الايقونيه لموقع تويتر
ووضع محله حرف اكس وقال ان تويتر سيعرف
الان باسم موقع اكس ويمكن للمستخدمين
البحث عن اكس دوت كوم للوصول الى الصفحه
الرئيسيه للموقع الشعار الجديد يشير الى
شركه اكس جروب التي اعلن ماسك تاسيسها
لتكون المالكه الرسميه للمنصه القرار لقي
التفاعلا كبيرا على المنصه لاسيما في ظل
التغييرات العديده التي احدثها ماسك منذ
استحواذه على تويتر في اكتوبر الماضي
بصفقه بلغت اربعه واربعين مليار دولار
لنقرا لكم بعض التهديدات او عفوا الاكسات
ربما
صار تقول بعد تغيير تويتر الى اكس ماذا
سيكون اسم التغريدات ويجيب حساب مصدر
مسؤول على هذا السؤال قائلا في تغريدته او
في اكسته ربما يعني معاد في غره فلان وغرد
علان صار في اكز فلان واكس علان نختم نشره
ان هذا الاسبوع بخبر اقتصادي اذ قرر البنك
المركزي الاوروبيه رفع اسعار الفائده
بواقع 25 نقطه اساس وذلك للمره التاسعه
على التواليب ليبلغ سعر الفائده على
الودائع ثلاثه وثلاثه ارباع في المئه وهو
اعلى مستوى لها منذ عام 2000 وفي امريكا
رفع الاحتياطي الفيدرالي معدل الفائده
الرئيسيه بمقدار ربع النقطه مئويه لتبلغ
بذلك اعلى مستوياتها في 22 عاما وهو ما
يرفع سعر الاقراض الاساسي الى خمسه ونصف
في ولكن ماذا يعني ذلك وما السبب هذا
الارتفاع معي الزميل يوسف خطاب مذيع نشره
الاقتصاديه في الجزيره ليوجيبا عن هذا
التساؤل يا مرحبا يوسف اهلا بكم محمد
ببساطه هذا التساؤل اجابته ان الفيدرالي
الامريكي يريد ان يسيطر على معدلات التضخم
التي وصلت الى حدود
وصل بها الى حدود الثلاثه في المئه في
الوقت الحاضر لكن هناك مخاوف ممن هذه
المخاوف المخاوف تتلخص في خوف من وصول
الاقتصاد الامريكي لمرحله الوقود نتيجه
احجام الشركات والافراد عن
الانفاق وبسبب اسعار الفائده المرتفعه
شكرا جزيلا لك يوسف شكرا لكم على متابعتي
ايجازنا نلتقي بحول الله الاسبوع المقبل
في ايجاز اخر وكنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]